you guys already know that I'm a part of
this thing called just kidding news
just kidding news is something that I'm
very passionate about because this show
it's very unique on the YouTube space
it's literally people talking about the
opinions whether it's right or wrong and
I know a lot of people when they watch
the videos like we can't believe you
said that you don't know the full story
of course we don't know the [ __ ] full
story we just read the article so you
guys have a lot more time to research it
but that's really what it is and we want
to show people that you know it's okay
to have an opinion on certain things
whether you're right or wrong and it's
unfiltered and it's wrong so I love this
channel and we're actually on our way to
go film an episode
and just kidding you there's always this
thing where they say on I'm late
constantly ten Oh something by the way
why I'm late I'm like five or six
minutes late
and it's only because I can't really
test traffic too well and every time I
show up early
other people show up like ten or fifteen
minutes late so I'm like you know what
I'm just gonna show finders late and
I'll always be on time lo and behold
who's late this time and I don't care
that the garage broke it doesn't matter
you're late barn geo showed like 40
minutes late
what's up tardy before the show I need
you to be quiet because right now what
time is it what did you give me last
week what time is it is the question
[ __ ] I'm only playing Gio I
absolutely love Bart [ __ ] to you ha ha I
feel the look see that it walked away in
the closet completely went overhead but
it might be some videos finally here
because Tiffany did impair our ability
Joe is such a interesting character he
has so many weapons I think he's getting
ready for a zombie apocalypse oh you
guys want to see something cool that I
got hold on that da matta FACA this bull
if he ever gets robbed I feel bad for
the person coming into his house he has
like a whole war chest yeah mother
Walking Dead Sea it's called chaos but
you may have a [ __ ] night chaos it's
about to go down you ever heard that
saying they should've never gave you
[ __ ] money that's Joe I think you're
just waiting for somebody to rob you
yeah you're like leaving a wad of cash
in the front of the house I'm not gonna
door yes ass a spear like 4 different
types of swords oh I gotta get some
cameras installed so as soon as we see
guys with like a mess or someone weird
coming in right it's gonna be dark in my
room so my door opens they're just gonna
hear like our three dogs this little
ones and right by my bed I have a
handguns vault
so in it snap and it's like all fancy to
impress upon it's all pretty kind of a
speaker in there it's only fingerprint
so no one can open it but me what the
[ __ ] that's tight so for like a snicker
imagine
okay bye India and then his other side
to him he has like a kazoo an accordion
I don't know what he's preparing for but
I think he's preparing to fight an army
on a Lonely Island instruments for JK
news and this is just in case someone
walks through that door 15 and if Bart
needs any assistance I would jump up and
stab you on that part of it I want there
to be like a weapon in your place
mm-hmm and it goes like kids Oh boom
just think about like a spirit boom boom
all it flies up yeah and then you wrap
grab it and you throw it in the
[ __ ] face the special guest for
today for just G news was furious Pete
never knew him prior to today actually
and various Pietist oh by the way super
talented I didn't realize he was a
professional eater
I just thought he was like this huge
bodybuilding guy he's like 3 inches tall
to me I'm 6 1 by the way and just just
yoked out dude but man I love that and I
[ __ ] want you news JK to me has
become an everyday thing so a lot of our
stuff aside just from being friends we
kind of mix friendship and business
together and it's been absolutely
amazing and I know they're the same like
you shouldn't do friendship and business
that's because your friends are probably
dumb as [ __ ] well can you blow your own
house ah
why because you only get to be violent
with me I never get to be violent with
you yeah but I do it out of love
I generally became rooted in LA because
of them coming to LA was a very
difficult thing for me it wasn't it
wasn't something that I was used to I
didn't like the environment and to be
honest with you
well majority the people I I didn't
really buy with as well but when I met
Martin Jo and Gio and them you know they
instantly became family
which is why we do stuff like just
getting together and a lot of the
sketches and I whenever they need me I'm
there for the 100 percent some people
they email TIFF and they go to okay
you'll be everybody does why are you
doing it because you're so nice
no are you telling me I'm gonna get more
oh yeah what is this move Tommy much
love and respect you live is he choosing
people's life and death much love
respect you get to live much love and
respect you live so I think he's like
playing Mortal Kombat finish him ballad
one of the things that I kinda was
really drawn towards them was the fact
that they were very honest and real even
though we disagree on a lot of things
like and then it happens there's no
animosity or hate and you don't see that
in a lot of people specifically here in
LA and my personal thing anyways like if
you disagree with somebody you
automatically hate them as a human being
which is dumb because you're not going
to have the same ideas but Marta Joe had
this way of of listening and disagreeing
at the same time which is something that
I I generally gained as well I mean you
may not see it in my videos because I'm
super opinionated because though the
communicator is supposed to make you
laugh but that's what really you know to
me towards them and that's not something
that I see a lot